the ultimate unit is a human being the
individual there's not a single person
in the world who could make this pencil
the people who go around talking about
their soft heart unfortunately it very
often extends to their head as well
there's no way to appreciate fully the
specific contributions of Milton
Friedman to the growth of libertarian
ideas and a free society this is the man
after all who introduced the concept of
school vouchers what we need to do is to
enable parents to have more say about
the school which their child goes to
documented the role of government
monopolies on money and creating
inflation inflation is just like
alcoholism the good effects come first
provided the intellectual arguments that
ended the military draft in America it
is long past time that we return to our
basic heritage got rid of the compulsion
in our military service he masterfully
drew a through line between economic
freedom and political and cultural
freedom capitalism is a necessary
condition for freedom but not a
sufficient condition yet his ultimate
contribution to freedom and liberty is
found less than any of the specific
arguments he made and more in the ways
he made them never yet known anybody who
is trying to defend a government program
who didn't say all the Tevas came from
the fact that it wasn't big enough
he provided an all-too-rare example of a
public intellectual who was scrupulously
honest forthright and fair in every
debate he entered you've got to compare
something with something will you tell
me the alternative whether he was duking
it out with fellow Nobel Prize winners
and other high-profile economists or
making the case for the morality of
capitalism with TV host Phil Donahue
where in the world you find these angels
who are going to organize society for us
well I don't even trust you to do that
he always argued in good faith admitted
when he was wrong and enlarged the
circle of debate long after some of
Friedman's technical points and social
insights have been superseded that
commitment to relentless inquiry and
search for truth wherever it takes us
will survive Milton Friedman gave us
something better than revealed truth he
showed us the process by which we might
continue to indefinitely learn about our
and the human condition it will take an
understanding of what freedom is to
realize the full potential of a truly
free society in this sense the Freedman
century is far from over
indeed it's just getting started